xavier riches est professeur émérite à
la sorbonne nouvelle et xavier richet
bonjour merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france
alors la loi de sécurité de hong kong
offre à la chine des prérogatives de
police pour un éventail de cas très
large on y trouve la lutte contre la
subversion le séparatisme la collusion
avec des forces étrangères notamment
elle finalement sont concernées toutes
les personnes qui c'est qui exprimerait
un désaccord avec la politique de pékin
on peut dire ça oui je pense même que la
chine
valls est en avance sur ce qui aurait dû
se passer en 2047 puisque vous savez que
la rétrocession de hong kong prévoyait
une période de 50 ans et donc pour les
motifs que le connaît les mouvements qui
se sont développées ces dernières années
un compte bien le chinois donc à
appliquer cette loi qui finalement
revient à une quasi alex e de hong kong
dans le giron de la chine continentale
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est la fin
20 pays d'un système
oui manifestement c'est la fin d'un pays
deux systèmes et ça pose un problème
d'ailleurs à la fois pour les pays
occidentaux qui commercent avec la chine
et hong kong est à la fois aussi par la
chine c'est à dire que pour la chine
hong kong représenté 10 ont une fenêtre
importante pas simplement en termes de
volume des changes
l'investissement direct etc mais aussi
en termes de facilité en quelque sorte
pour rejoindre les marchés occidentaux
l'exemple c'est le cas du rnb
internationale c'est à dire la place de
hong kong pour jouer et essayer de dates
analyser la monnaie chinoise etc
donc ça c'est un problème important
parce que certainement ça va avoir un
impact sur sur la chine mais aussi pour
les pays occidentaux hong kong
qu'on veuille ou non c'est ainsi la
porte d'entrée et la possibilité de
développer leurs affaires en chine
continentale sur la chine de chine
populaire alors donc on voit bien que
finalement les les à la fois la chine se
trouve un peu contrainte par ce problème
sera gêné sur le plan économique mais
aussi les polices occidentaux dans la
mesure où il ya des intérêts ne peut
part et d'autre à dix on a joué à
profiter de ce cocon reportées jusqu ici
alors on a entendu justement les
inquiétudes de l'union européenne et du
royaume-uni comment la communauté
internationale aujourd'hui peut se
positionner sur le dossier
est-ce qu'elle a abandonné on compte
finalement à son sort 2 je crois en fait
disent oh je suppose
sans être pessimiste que dans les fêtes
oui puisque finalement qu'est-ce que les
européennes qu'est ce que les états unis
peuvent faire contre la chine vont on
est entré dans une phase aujourd'hui
découplage entre la chine la quotité
d'impôt de l'eau pour teinter thulliez
les états unis l'europe et c'est grâce à
une politique une position un peu
intermédiaire entre les deux mais de
fait on est entré dans une phase où
disons il ya des conflits plus ouvert il
y aura des comme aux dires des actions
qui seront plus forte dans ce domaine
pour savoir qui fait quoi et quel type
de relation on va confier à entretenir
avec la chine mais finalement sept mois
ne risque-t-elle pas aussi de refroidir
les futurs investisseurs à hong kong
le problème donc c'est une place
importante pour revendre ça a été
important puces pour les facilités que
la place elle mêle soul et si on prend
la place de hong kong dont les
exportations de la chine c'est plus que
3 % c'est quelque chose de résiduel
aujourd'hui ce sont des grandes villes
de la région qui ont pris l'ascendant
sur hong kong donc c'est plus tellement
la place économique que la place de deux
comme aux dires de transition de
plateformes que présenté un conte donc
ça certainement
ça va être un enjeu très importante
pourquoi on va voir des chiens
donc c'est un talent peut-être qu'ils
vont quitter hong kong d'une part mais
on va voir aussi des chiens occidental
qui vont rester et qui vont être marqués
par disons qu'ils vont rester dans la
mesure où elles sont liées au grand
marché chinois donc simuler c'est un peu
ça
l'enjeu c'est à dire l'arbitrage que
vont être obligés de faire déchirer
entre 10 ont quitté leur compte parce
que les difficultés il devient pop et
groen ou bien la perspective de rester
parce que on a toujours accès au marché
chinois aux gros marché chinois alors
cette dernière question comment se
fait-il finalement que les hongkongais
et puis faire reculer en souviens car il
a sur la loi sur l'extradition c'était
l'an dernier et pas cette fois c'est lié
aux collines écoutez je crois que bon
les lélés hong kong et ont été
extrêmement courageux tout au long de
ces dernières années mais aujourd'hui
bon la chine a pris des mesures
radicales donc était pas prévu et on a
vu l'instauration de cette fois a été
décrétée très rapidement alors peut-être
le coville a empêché qui est désigne la
publicité autour de cette fois mais si
on prend la manière dont a été présenté
voilà un mois seulement à la conférence
nationale à pékin et dans la foulée a
piqué peut-être locaux vides a profité
d'une opportunité mais cette aide
c'était dans les tuyaux enfin disons et
de ce point de vue là le le rouleau
compresseur est là et je crois que c'est
ça qui déstabilise et qui va
certainement malheureusement freiné les
velléités des eaux kong et de ceux comme
aux dires de lutter contre cette cette
mesure merci beaucoup xavier richaud
d'avoir partagé votre expertise sur
notre antenne je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur émérite à l'université
sorbonne nouvelle